yes yeah what are you scared about I'm
scared of living life to the full bucket
list life mate
like a giant baby I'm gonna beat these
guys
[Music]
[Applause]
we all have our bucket lists a lot of
people have bucket lists and we're all
going to choose items from our bucket
list each episode to determine what
belongs on the ultimate bucket list is
every cent to me it makes total sense to
me and it's a good for I don't
understand
behold the bucket list Emma picks
something on your bucket list that you
really really really want to do I want
to do everything on here but like a top
a top one I'm going to say drive a tank
and specifically run a car over with a
tank yes theme of this episode then
vehicles all right you're gonna go drive
a tank can you actually do that just
sort of sounds illegal
Dominic day
my friend is the Queen's bugler he
actually is I did his wedding to me tank
limo
well it's your take the limo I've cut
two of these in half joined them
together and I've made a tank limo got a
pink tank yeah you gotta have a pink
tank we did that for Gay Pride
guy has about 150 tanks this is a cool
looking tank this is the monster Bentley
it popped up on eBay he probably has
more tanks and an arm this is a tank
hurt ridiculous
but what is this mission a life and it's
not like no that would be like just so
many things I'll be scared of instead of
people joining the army to drive the
tank you can just come a buy one off me
or you can come and drive one huija buy
off no the one round the corner which we
found the golden we got that for eBay so
you just put go tank on eBay yes if you
were military but this darling yeah what
a girl you've been asleep for the last
year and a half we were restoring a tank
down the corner there's a hole in the
bottom and he puts his hand in and pins
out a gong bar what that's the one we
found the golden there was this terrible
rumor that we've found more than five
bars ha how could anyone think such a
thing no no no it's just a rumor I was
hoping to drive the biggest tanker they
have well the biggest one I've got at
the moment is off the film Fast and
Furious 6 and that is what we're using
for crushing all you've got to beat even
beat these thing oh so we're competing
for who gets to drive one perfect driver
I don't know who yet I'm looking at
those boots and they're almost riding
boots what do you think of my boots
beautiful on the beach
I don't feel so intimidating what's the
weirdest thing you found in a time bar
from the gold the grenade launcher art
from Earth m16s there - mmm just to be
clear there's no grenades not that I
know of
by the board acceleration of the right
foot great big thing and then on the
left that you've got a in the jet to see
what wait wait why you so calm about it
like it's just that you're not wearing
parachute so you would be made aware of
it I was expecting something a little
more modern maybe a little cleaner I'm
slightly on edge that I'm gonna step on
a landmine or something there's just so
much to be scared of me who has that
many times he's got scary dogs if you've
got a jet ski with a gun it looks like
there's like wasps driving a tank was
actually on my bucket list - I didn't
know there's gonna be a competition
though I've been in the car with rich
before save just say I'm gonna be better
than him I'm ready I'm gonna beat these
guys
[Music]
try to tell me to press the ejector seat
I'm loving this very there's a lot
petrol revving [ __ ] [ __ ]
to do with a windscreen
that's too deep my publisher suspects
this can't be good god that's amazing
not a good backseat driver I really want
a tank I don't you should never have a
tactic
I'm not 30% off in the scores before we
even studied but I wouldn't even let you
wash my tank one hands down so she gets
to crush the car yeah no I sell it
[Music]
it look great this is the Shamus my car
I've take this off my bucket list
apparently my fashion sense is very
military so a lot of tank tops do you
want to know what we're doing more than
anything
yes a gyrocopter have you seen James
Bond like James Bond You Only Live Twice
yeah say I have there's a gyrocopter in
it gyrocopter is like a little
helicopter it's just a chair in the sky
you see powder probably I'm not flying
yeah no it's on your bucket list to die
reporting live from the airfields from
the movie alien no it's actually James
Bond
Johnny the toys keeps talking about this
James Bond movie so we're doing we're
about to take flight except we were
dropped at the wrong entrance I feel
like this was intentional sabotage to
try to not do this experience I'm not
Zener grab yeah it's too windy none
okay scared what are you scared about
I'm scared of dying
look out tiny days excitement level one
to ten
no it's just I'll just share myself
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's hi I'm six feet that's a lot of
me my name is Phil Harwood and you're
the gyrocopter expedience in York who
are going to go and fly and see what
it's like from the air wait to think a
gyrocopter looks like a helicopter
because it's got big spinning rotor
blades it actually flies like an
aeroplane and it's got a built-in
parachute mode it's the base but it's
all in one aircraft and that's what
makes it safe and that what makes it the
best aircraft I am excited yeah Wendy
isn't it one of the big advantages of a
gyroplane over an aeroplane is we don't
fuel turbulence this is the ultimate
magic carpet this is on my bucket list
and I saw it in a James Bond movie you
saw it and you only left twice with
little Nelly who ain't and fired all
these missiles I thought you were making
that up
no how far can you go on a gyroplane we
have taken off from here and with two or
three stops we ended up in Germany we
use it as a form of transport what
happens if you like you want to go to
Tesco you take a car okay Emma level of
once turn excitement nine I'm 10 out of
10 of both Joe be just lit my mouth
fantastic I think this could genuinely
qualify for the ultimate bucket list
there is no way that this could be
cooler than driving a tank over a car my
bucket this one is better because you
won't die it keeps having to say it's
safe which means is not safe it looks
like a toy kids don't have fix they do
they're stupid
I do I said no and they don't have the
flamethrower and the Rockets like he did
I think it belongs on the big list you
have a joke joke mind the mood for jokes
Tom Cruise didn't need someone in like
put his helmet on your head
[Music]
I was all right and then I was into
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's just the way
I liked it you definitely just party
because that you don't own that outfit
he's gonna do the whole time
he's waving he's happy it belongs on the
ultimate list right yeah yeah you're
gonna top it no you have to tell us what
we're doing it looks like you're doing
something really illegal well we're
gonna do it away I'm gonna take you back
in time
what'd you hear about the lumberjack
pilot
he was like dials check switches check
shirt check joke screamed like a baby we
have to do a real thing I'm taking you
back in time what we doing right now
it's a secret do a list it's full of
stuff that's not real inventing your
animal right as possible
I ain't gonna do that job you got two
animals yeah having us visit the moon
for a bit milk a cow yes why this is the
end of the episode it's got to be really
good is it epic yeah
well this is a epic finale stood in a
field they'll be where are you I'm
waving my hands yeah some people said it
like Nicolas Cage there is good to speak
how are you there is that this ladies
and gentlemen is a penny-farthing or
ordinary cuz that was the actual name
for it this one here is rather big this
is fifty two point six inches on the
wheel this would be made in about 1885
there's a clamp brake on the front here
now if you press too hard you'll
actually throw the bike over the front
do you remember press really hard yeah
yeah this isn't a tire it's solid rubber
there's no air in there whatsoever
there's enough air in Joe's head we
don't need any in the time well the back
end of the 1800s a lot of circus acts
picked up the bike and that's why now
people sort of go did to do or level of
excitement joke through the roof maybe
we should get you a hat I can't believe
Joe actually pulled something off to the
point that he was able to book it they
doubt with me they're not about me
anymore
I'm more excited to sit to see him
attempt to do it I heard it's just like
riding a bike when I kick the bucket
that list will be complete the list is
in the bucket the bucket lists will be
completed I made my point it looks a bit
like the top hat but he's actually a
helmet up over it good lads
[Music]
come on Joe come on
beautiful dismount what happened to your
call string I feel we conquered the
training boats but I am very scared
because that bike is like twice the size
but like I should have worn more
appropriate shorts I'm ready
this is the bucket list moment oh is up
[Music]
I can't let go all right
she is very cool
[Music]
of going back in time cross it off your
list
ride a penny-farthing right next to ride
and ostrich you're not doing that one
day that guys is decide what's on the
ultimate bucket list section tanks need
to be on the altar bug list that is it I
crush a car stuff in there I say the
winner is the gyrocopter
I was so scared and now I feel like I
can fly an airplane I'm not going to get
into an airplane with you ever I was
gonna say penny farthing I thought it
was great but now that you've chosen
mine I'm gonna obviously get behind mine
and say yep guy Rakata ultimate bucket
list
Joe each thing in one word tank manly
gyrocopter beautiful penny farthing old
it's like us manly beautiful beautiful
old I'm not old you are you're older
[Music]
[Music]